Spider-Man across the spider verse is
practically bursting with spider people
and most of them actually have
significant origins in the comic books
wondering what those Origins are we're
here to explain spoilers ahead
Spider-Man across the spider-verse opens
with Earth 65's Spider-Woman Gwen Stacy
giving the audience a glimpse of her
life after the events of Spider-Man into
the spider-verse we learned that this
version of spider-gwen has an origin
story similar to her comic book
counterparts which occurred in edge of
spider-verse issue 2. after receiving
powers from the bite of an irradiated
spider she establishes a secret identity
and fights crime as a vigilante her best
friend Peter Parker transforms himself
into the lizard accidentally dying in
their ensuing battle Gwen's father
police officer George Stacy mistakenly
assumes that Spider-Woman murdered the
boy frightened and uncertain about her
relationships in future she jumps at the
chance to join the spider Society this
sprawling team of spider-powered
superheroes from different Earths have
banded together under Earth 928's Miguel
O'Hara to prevent the fabric of the
Multiverse from being destroyed by
Dimension hopping anomalies along the
way she also discovers the shocking
truth about her only other friend Miles
Morales the Spider-Man of Earth 1610 and
why he can never join the society
however going against the group's
directives she catches up with Miles
during a mission it's an impulsive
choice that leads to disastrous
consequences Gwen eventually finds
herself kicked out of the society as
miles is stranded on a hostile
unfamiliar Earth however the drummer who
never belonged decides to form her own
band of old and new spider friends to
locate and rescue miles
the protagonist of the spider-verse
trilogy Miles Morales is the sole
Spider-Man of Earth 1610 and operates in
Brooklyn over a year has passed since
the events of into the spider-verse with
Miles fully embracing his role as his
City's super powered protector complete
with a new costume that he designed
himself my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brookings one and only Spider-Man he
crosses paths with the spot an apparent
joke of a villain who rapidly transforms
into a terrifying threat over the course
of the film miles learns about the
existence of the spider Society
following an unexpected visit from his
friend Earth 65's Gwen Stacy who was
secretly sent to his Earth to Monitor
and detain the spot unbeknownst to her
miles follows her through a multiversal
portal as she tracks down the villain
there his actions nearly cause the
destruction of another Spider-Man's
world at the society's headquarters he's
denied membership to the group and
discovers that he was the original
anomaly the spider that bit him was from
Earth 42 and was supposed to bite that
world spider person not him worse the
society tries to stop him from leaving
his father's life as the death of
someone close to them is a Canon event
that all spiders must suffer unwilling
to accept this miles makes a desperate
bid to go home outmaneuvering the entire
Society in the process however he lands
on Earth 42 instead and is captured by
that world's Prowler Miles Morales cross
the spider verse builds upon the
post-credits scene of its predecessor by
formally introducing Miguel O'Hara the
Spider-Man of Earth 928 this
Spider-Man's Dimension is set in the
year 2099 and New York has transformed
into the technologically advanced city
of Nueva York aided by his hollow
assistant Lila Miguel forms the spider
Society taking it upon himself to
maintain order across what he calls the
arachnohumanoid poly Multiverse
interestingly he has some major beef
with Miles Morales he blames miles for
being the very first Multiverse anomaly
and into the spider-verse this version
of Spider-Man 2099 is barely
recognizable from the original who first
appeared in 1992's Spider-Man 2099
number one the Miguel we scene across
the spider verse is an angry torture
Soul traumatized by his past failings
completely devoid of a sense of humor
and prone to throwing objects in a fit
of rage while not an outright villain he
antagonizes miles to a cruel degree
aside from revealing that miles's father
is fated to die and prohibiting him from
doing anything about it Miguel also
tells the fledgling superhero that he's
nothing more than a mistake and that he
was never meant to be Spider-Man by the
movie's end Miguel and his Strike Team
are hunting miles across the Multiverse
and it's clear that this vampire ninja
Spider-Man will stop at nothing to keep
the spider-verse cannon intact the First
new spider character introduced in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse is
Jessica drew the afrode arachna-themed
defender of a yet unrevealed Earth
designation a tough as Nails tough love
giving motorcycle riding mother to be
this whip slinging Wonder fearlessly
jumps into battle she instantly makes a
strong impression on spider Gwen whom
she invites to the society and takes
under her Wing as a protege the original
version of Jessica Drew was introduced
in 1977's Marvel Spotlight number 32 and
she's been given a major revamp in many
ways for her Silver Screen animation
debut while not much is known about the
origin story of Jessica's across the
spider-verse iteration it is clear that
the society's de facto leader Miguel
O'Hara trusts her considerably to the
point where she basically acts as his
second in command she is also critical
of Peter B Parker's mentoring skills
hardly hesitating to point to miles is
proof that he is a terrible teacher
initially Jessica is strict towards Gwen
emphasizing that the latter is her star
student and downright disapproving of
her continued association with Miles she
even does nothing when Miguel expels
Gwen from the society and sends her home
by the film's end however Jessica seems
proud that Gwen has taken the initiative
to search for Miles herself without the
society support
during the sequence where the spot first
explores the possibilities of his
growing Powers he takes a quick detour
to Earth 13122 the home of Lego
Spider-Man this unique take on the web
Slinger was completely absent in the
promotional materials leading up to the
release of Spider-Man across the
spider-verse however his inclusion was
revealed during the main cast's
interview with Fandango surprisingly
Lego Peter Parker plays a much bigger
role than just a blink and you'll miss
at Cameo after the black and white
Baddie shows up in the Lego Universe and
destroys a chunk of The Daily Bugle
building we learned that Lego Peter
Parker witnessed the whole event taking
a quick break from Jay Jonah Jameson's
hot-headed hassling the mild-mannered
minifigure hides in a different room and
transforms into Lego Spider-Man he
activates his spider Society device and
reports the incident to Miguel O'Hara
who thanks him and calls him one of
their best Spider-Man Lego Spider-Man is
a welcome addition here and also
represents a full circle moment of sorts
the first official Lego sets featuring
the hero were tie-ins for Sam Rainey
Spider-Man released in 2002 with that
said the Lego Spider-Man we see in
across the spider-verse is based on the
version that came with the comic
inspired Daily Bugle set which came out
in 2021 when Gwen Stacy is ordered to
find and arrest the spot in Earth
50101's mom baton an invisible Miles
Morales secretly follows her as a result
miles also meets Gwen's contact and
spider Society teammate there pavita
prabarker that Earth Spider-Man
introduced as a lighthearted Soul who
absolutely Revels in being Spider-Man
paviter gracefully swings through the
city with his web Bengals showing a
natural gift for super heroics despite
being a superhero for just six months
Spider-Man is so easy I find a few bad
guys quick break for a guy with my my
auntie he is also quick to sense the
Romantic tension between miles and Gwen
and doesn't hesitate to bring it up
multiple times while sharply poking fun
at Western stereotypes of Indian culture
during their fight against the spot
unfortunately this encounter paves the
way for a demonstration of the
consequences of multiversal meddling
when miles prevents a cannon event by
Saving Earth 50101's inspector Singh
from being crushed by debris paviter's
reality begins to collapse we then see
the spider society's Multiverse repair
team on the scene planting devices that
were designed to prevent dimensional
incursions in the comics the character
first appeared in 2005's Spider-Man
India number one there he Sports a
costume that is much closer in
appearance to the classic Spider-Man
suit but with white pants and red
pointed shoes Additionally the comics
version of pavita operates in Mumbai
rather than a made-up location whenever
applicable across the spider-verse makes
sure that each spider character
incorporates visual aspects of their
respective Dimensions into their overall
aesthetic there is no better example of
this than the Spider-Man of Earth 138
Hobie Brown the spider Punk a literal
walking Lodge of newspapers and band
posters the anarchic spider Punk Cooley
strums his guitar In the Heat of battle
bringing electrifying energy wherever he
goes while never hesitating to give the
man the middle finger Hovey lends a much
needed assistance to spider Gwen miles
and pavita prabarker at a critical
Moment On Earth 50101 as they try to
stop the spot from activating alcamax's
super collider in that reality he also
accompanies miles and Gwen to the spider
Society HQ on Earth 928 where it quickly
becomes clear that he and Miguel O'Hara
mutually dislike each other in one
sequence Hobie is thrilled when Peter B
Parker's daughter Mayday fills her
diaper while Miguel is holding her
saluting the child while calling the ACT
taking a crap on the establishment
crucially Hobie helps miles escape from
captivity taking advantage of the
ensuing chaos at the spider Society HQ
to quit later on his friendship with
Gwen becomes a massive boom when both
miles and Gwen go Rogue the project
bootleg Dimension hopping device he
leaves for her on Earth 65 enables Gwen
to recruit her trusted spider allies to
join her Splinter Group foreign the
spidermobile is one of the oddest yet
most iconic parts of Spider-Man's comic
book History built together by
Spider-Man and his best bud the Human
Torch the spidermobile made its first
full appearance in 1974's Amazing
Spider-Man number 130 but was rendered
unusable roughly 30 issues later still
it has been brought back repeatedly in
the books as both a functional vehicle
and a museum display piece much to the
webslinger's embarrassment in recent
years however its most noteworthy
comeback was in 2015's Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 3 number 12. not as a
vehicle for Spider-Man to ride but as a
legitimate sentient Spider-Man variation
from Earth 53931 this version of the
spidermobile along with the secret
identity of Peter parked Carr makes an
appearance in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse it is perhaps the sheer
Ridiculousness of parked Carr's
existence that earned it a few seconds
in the spotlight the spidermobile is one
of the few spider Society members miles
gets officially introduced to complete
with its Earth designation in a caption
box while he explores the facilities of
the spider Society HQ with spider Gwen
Spiderman Monk and Jessica Drew parked
Carr also joins the rest of the society
in trying to apprehend miles but it
humorously fails to cross the web
tightrope held by another spider variant
one look at the Scarlet Spider in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse would
be enough for any Comics fan to know
that this version of Ben Reilly embodies
the essence of grim and gritty 1990s
comics from heavily Inked head to toe
unfortunately fans who were expecting a
respectable interpretation of the fan
favorite spider clone are unlikely to
find it in this iteration hailing from
Earth 94 a reference to the character's
first appearance as the Scarlet Spider
in 1994's web of Spider-Man number 118
the Ben Reilly we meet in this movie is
a tongue-in-cheek caricature of 90s
comic book cliches from his
unnecessarily verbose descriptions of
otherwise mundane objects his obsession
with muscles and hitting the perfect
pose and his penchant for whiny
introspection it's a Herculean challenge
to take this character seriously
particularly because he takes himself
too seriously the Scarlet Spider joins
Miguel O'Hara and Jessica Drew during
the film's third act as they search for
Miles Morales on Earth 1610
unfortunately his peculiar mannerisms
and profound lack of awareness quickly
become his undoing spider-gwen makes
short work of him tricking him into
getting sucked into her bootleg portal
while separating him from his Dimension
Crossing device at this point it's
anyone's guess if he'll show up in the
next film and if he'll be more than just
a walking stereotype plate for Laughs
when miles first steps into the spider
Society HQ he meets a mind-blowing array
of spider characters with different
abilities still this doesn't stop the
excited youth from introducing himself
as Spider-Man to the cyberspace spider
hero called spider bite who
sarcastically deadpans whoa no way all
of us are in across the spider verse
margot's digital Avatar acts as the
gatekeeper of sorts for the spider
Society operating from the control room
one of spider bites responsibilities is
to send the Multiverse Crossing super
villains the society detains back to
their respective Dimensions as the
resonant arachnid-themed Avenger of
Earth 22191 this version of Margot Kess
could just as easily be another virtual
extension of her comic book counterpart
who first appeared in 2018's Vault
spiders number one after successfully
eluding the entire spider Society miles
uses his ability to turn invisible to
evade marico's gaze and sneaks into the
teleporter in an attempt to send himself
back to Earth 1610 however because the
teleporter selects where to send its
passenger based on the origin of their
powers it mistakenly sends miles to
Earth 42 the home dimension of the
spider that bit him crucially Margot
gets an opportunity to reboot the system
and prevent miles from escaping but Ops
to not do anything instead she lets him
beam out of their HQ so it's no surprise
when she shows up as a member of
spider-gwen's newly formed Rogue faction
in the film's final scenes of course it
wouldn't be a proper spider-verse movie
without everyone's favorite easy-going
spider Sensei Peter B Parker watch this
he's gonna say you've got 24 hours
you've got 24 hours
this time around it looks like the old
tired Spider-Man of Earth 616 or as
Spider punk calls him humbling reality
Spider-Man has managed to finally pick
himself up and get his act together he
has also traded his homeless Dimension
displaced get up from into the
spider-verse for a proper set of threats
specifically a pink bathrobe and baby
harness in other words the dad bought
Spider-Man has become an actual dad upon
his return to his own Dimension Peter
reconciles with Mary Jane Watson their
rekindled love results in the birth of
their daughter Mayday who has inherited
her father's amazing spider powers ever
the devoted parent Peter made her a web
shooting bracelet as it turns out
Peter's adventures with Miles Morales in
the previous film helped him get over
his fear of becoming a parent he even
admits as much to his Protege during
their brief but heated conversation
after miles breaks out of the spider
Society HQ after miles escapes Peter
returns to his Homeworld setting Mayday
in her crib and half-heartedly denying
to MJ that he brought their kid on
another fight however this quiet night
at the Parker household comes to an end
when spider-gwen pops up in Peter's
backyard through hobie's Dimension
hopping device as expected Peter decides
to join Gwen in her search for miles
when the first trailer for Spider-Man
across the spider-verse was released
eagle-eyed spider fans immediately
spotted a familiar albeit largely
forgotten version of the web Slinger
mixed in with the rest of the spider
Society the Peter Parker of Earth
751-263 otherwise known as Spider-Man
Unlimited from the eponymous 1999
cartoon this small detail got many fans
excited as it pretty much confirmed the
likelihood of other more popular
animated Spider-Man showing up in across
the spiderverse as well true enough
subsequent promotional materials
revealed that the Spider-Man of the fan
favorite Spectacular Spider-Man animated
series from 2008 designated as Earth
26496 is also part of the movie while
unlimited didn't really get to do
anything significant during the film's
run time spectacular gets two moments to
shine aside from a scene during Miguel
O'Hara's arachnohumanoid poly Multiverse
explainer depicting spectacular's
version of the ASM 90 Cannon event voice
actor Josh Keaton briefly reprises his
role he gets to deliver a one-liner
meant to dissuade miles from preventing
Earth's 1610's Canon event the death of
his father the recently promoted Captain
Jeff Morales one not so surprising
inclusion is the Spider-Man from Earth
67 the Spider-Man from the pointing me
the 67 Spider-Man joins the society in
pursuing miles bravely announcing his
arrival before demonstrating his
signature ineffectiveness by swinging
way too slow to catch the Renegade
spider it's safe to say that one of the
biggest questions on everyone's Minds
about across the spider verse was with
Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield and Tom
Holland be part of the movie after all
we recently witnessed the live-action
spider Trio makes cinematic history in
2021 Spider-Man no way home so it would
make sense for them to be in another
Multiverse spanning spider flick the
answer is sort of both Maguire the
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man of
Earth 96283 and Garfield The Amazing
Spider-Man of
earth120703 plays small roles in across
the spider verse Miguel explains to
miles that every Spider-Man must go
through a Canon event that involves a
character close to the webslinger of the
universe dying in a tragic way during
the explanation a few seconds of the
death of Captain George Stacy from 2012
The Amazing Spider-Man to show moments
later the death of Uncle Ben arguably
the Canon event of Canon events for most
versions of Spider-Man becomes the focus
of the discussion in the background we
see Snippets of Maguire and Cliff
Robertson's Ben Parker who dies in 2002
Spider-Man meanwhile Hall and Spider-Man
doesn't appear at all although he does
get mentioned in the first few minutes
of across the spider verse don't even
get me started on Doctor Strange and a
little nerd back on Earth 1999.99
while many members of the spider society
and across the spider-verse can easily
be described as Spider-Man variants
based on their costumes there are a
handful with distinct visual elements
that make them stand out from the spider
crowd undoubtedly one of them is Max
Bourne the Spider-Man of 2211 who hails
from the comic book world of Earth 9500
this futuristic Spider-Man takes the
arachnid aesthetic to a whole new level
aside from his multi-eyed helmet he also
Sports 4 red appendages protruding from
what looks like a metallic backpack in
across the spider-verse Spider-Man 2211
briefly steals the show near the
beginning of Miles Morales extended
Chase sequence when the teenager
hilariously clings to Bourne's Crimson
carapace in a feeble attempt to hide
from the rest of the society this also
causes the society to mistake born for
miles for a few seconds emphasizing that
the group has become so large that they
don't even know one another's names
interestingly enough Spider-Man 2211's
first appearance was in a comic book
that featured two different versions of
the webslinger meeting the 1995 One-Shot
Spider-Man 2099 meets Spider-Man number
one similar to his role in this film
Spider-Man 2211's job in that comic is
to help preserve the Integrity of the
timeline he appears in the nick of time
to save Peter Parker and Miguel O'Hara
from being erased from existence via the
retcon bombs of the hobgoblin of 2211.
as part of the marketing efforts for
across the spiderverse Sony released a
clip welcoming audiences to the spider
Zoo indeed there's a mini menagerie of
spider-powered animals who somehow
qualified for spider Society membership
among the first we meet is Widow
nicknamed spider horse the trusty masked
Steed of Patrick O'Hara the cowboy
Spider-Man of Earth 31913 there's also
spider cat a character originally from
2011's spider Island I love New York
City number one who spits up a web
hairball in Miles Morales face spider
monkey from the Marvel Apes Dimension
also appears a few times in the extended
Chase sequence though the spider-powered
simeon's agility does little good in
helping the society apprehend miles the
most attention-grabbing spider creature
here however is spider Rex a
Tyrannosaurus Rex in a Spider-Man
costume complete with web shooters
around its tiny wrists a recent Comics
creation that debuted in 2022's edge of
spider-verse number one spider Rex was
originally a Pteranodon simultaneously
bitten by a T-Rex and smashed by a
meteorite with alien spider stowaways a
Freaky Friday situation ensues with the
pterodon now inhabiting the T-Rex's body
inexplicably clad in a spider themed
suit it can get weirder Nicholas Cage
told Screen Rant in January 2023 that
Sony did not reach out to him to reprise
his role as Spider-Man Noir and into the
spider-verse neither kamiko Glenn nor
John Mulaney who played Penny Parker and
spider-ham confirmed their participation
washing hopes for the secondary spider
Trio's return in across the spider-verse
as it turns out however the multiversal
pals do pop up unexpectedly and it looks
like they'll play even bigger roles in
the next film Beyond the spider verse
the first of the three to appear in
across the spider-verse is Penny who was
seen piloting an upgraded more
streamlined version of her companion
spider's robotic costume after the
original was destroyed in the previous
movie's final battle this new mechanical
suit closely resembles its comic book
counterpart as seen in 2014's edge of
spider verse number five as for spider
ham and Spider-Man Noir the two show up
at the end of the film as members of
spider-gwen's Splinter spider Squad to
help her outmaneuver Miguel O'Hara's
fighter society and find mile first
Miguel O'Hara's spider Society spans the
entirety of the spider-verse and
features both existing characters and
original Heroes created for across the
spider-verse a good number of the spider
Society members draw design inspiration
from established spider folks but aren't
100 accurate to their multimedia
counterparts for example one character
looks like aragnito Jr while a few are
wearing different version of Earth 616
Spider-Man's various spider armors one
Society member resembles Spider-Man's
brutal clone a spider side others draw
inspiration from characters like I
apayak and Julia Carpenter's
Spider-Woman some fans even reportedly
spotted takuya Yamashiro toei's
live-action Spider-Man in the mix we
also see spinneret in spiderling
mangaverse Spider-Man from Earth 2301
and a version of the bombastic Bag Man
curiously the Spider-Man from the
Insomniac game Universe appears not once
but twice one wearing his PS4 Advanced
suit and the other rocking the suit from
Marvel's Spider-Man 2 for the PS5 and as
expected many of these characters don't
really do anything significant in the
film meanwhile the spider Varian created
for across the spider-verse include
Malala Windsor AKA spider UK of Earth
835 cyborg Spider-Woman and the spider
Sona of Metro Boomin who worked on the
across the spider-verse soundtrack
foreign